[Applause]
good job
[Applause]
[Applause]
Toronto thank you for having me thank
you for the walk warm welcome there's
there's a lot of things we can cover we
decided to do a ton of QA so I've only
got a short period of time here to kind
of spit it and so what I'm going to
really focus on in this kind of moment
is gonna pipi piggyback off the last
presentation which is a lot of this is
about mindset and overall strategy of
how you're navigating your life and your
business life and your personal life
this is just about do you see what's
happening or don't you do you understand
how this plays out in the macro or are
you too consumed with the things that
are in front of you in the short term
it's really hard to project blockchains
impact on our society if you're just
caught up in the headlines of Bitcoin
right and so for me as I navigate my my
life and think about why things have
worked for me as I go under one very
basic assumption which is as long as I
stay alive it's always better to think
long-term than short-term and the other
thing that runs in parallel to that
strategy is my inability to allow one of
your opinions to matter more to me than
my own opinion about myself not because
I think I'm great or special it's just
that I think you suck at [ __ ] too
so for me the themes of what's been
happening why
entrepreneurship has been put on a
pedestal and is popular what's happening
with the Internet at its maturity the
fact that there's so many phones being
held up right now all these different
things that are happening what does it
really mean what it means is there's a
group of people a small percentage of
people that navigate their life
decisions from a place of confidence and
emotional stability and think in terms
of legacy and impact and and things in
the long game there's a group of people
that think about insecurities needing to
buy things to cover up their
insecurities so they need cash in the
short term because a pair of supremes or
a BMW is gonna close the gap of their
insecurity and then there's the
in-between and so for me I'm very
focused on the fact that the stuff that
I believe in seemed like a fairytale or
[ __ ] just thirty years ago because
the internet didn't exist for all the
youngsters that I see in the audience
they don't understand the world
pre-internet they don't understand a
world pre smartphone I'm [ __ ] old I
remember I was eighteen before I ever
spent 24 hours on a computer in my
lifetime I know what the world looked
like it wasn't practical to have debt
and work you're nine to seven and then
come home and make something of yourself
I struggle to complain about anything in
a world that is this special you can
decide to look at something narrow and
the side stuff sucks or you a
shortcoming or you can understand the
macro and let's call it very simply what
it is because it's truth this is the
greatest moment to be alive in the
history of the human race
[Applause]
and so for me I take it super macro or
if I wake up this morning and none of
the seven or eight people that I love
the most died overnight I'm optimistic I
feel in control
there's oh is [ __ ] let me how many
people here are an entrepreneur or
aspire to be one great for all the
youngsters in here let me give you the
first thing that I believe is true about
entrepreneurship it's lonely as [ __ ]
right because when you don't succeed on
a team or in school or at a job here's
what you do
team it was my player teammates fault
school [ __ ] the teachers right work my
boss is a [ __ ] idiot
when you fail in entrepreneurship all
eyes on you your fault you and guess
what everybody's watching so we're
living right now through a very
glamorous moment of entrepreneurship
where it's cool where a lot of people
want to put it in their Instagram photo
and profile because it tells the world
who they are to me it's an interesting
time for entrepreneurship anything that
swings too far one way or the other
becomes vulnerable when the global
economy and definitely the US economy
different than the Canadian one when the
US economy collapses because we are
loaning way too much money to kids that
are carrying enormous college debt and
aren't making enough to pay their debt
back let alone the house or car or thing
they're buying with their loan when the
US economy crashes because of college
debt and the economy really suffers two
things will fall in popular opinion
number one the institution of colleges
in the United States number two the
fantasy of entrepreneurship 98 percent
of the hands that just went up will fail
and work in a job in six years yet
everybody just thought I'm one of the
two percent that is it which is [ __ ]
awesome and do it and I can't wait for
you two
kill it but I will say that while we are
talking about all these things right now
my propaganda my push my want for people
to debate during this talk is not that
I'm gonna ride you up and you're gonna
go [ __ ] crush your business but I am
gonna hope to put pressure on everybody
in this room to get really self-aware
really fast
I think the reason I have a happy life
and things have gone well and more
importantly forget about me being a
focus group of one everybody that I know
that has happiness traces back to some
incredible incredible commitment to
self-awareness an incredible thing
happens in your life when you stop
bullshitting yourself look I wish I was
a lot of things too I wish I was the
quarterback of the New York Jets not
gonna happen I wish I was a supermodel
not gonna happen I wish a lot of things
too but when you romanticize and wish
instead of actually being practical and
understands you create a vulnerability
and let me remind some this group of
people about something that's very
important to me by show hands who's
under 30 years old raise your hands
[ __ ] actually actually I want I want
everybody under see what I thank you for
the lights if you were under 30 I want
you to stand up
that's what's up
so publicans keep staying up because I
want this a couple things number one one
of my least favorite things in society
right now is the demonization of the
youth and saying like Millennials are
lazy and entitled that straight [ __ ]
[ __ ] ninety percent of our friends
were [ __ ] lazy too
however on the flip side here's my
biggest concern for everybody who's
standing everybody who's standing has
one fatal flaw in the game of
entrepreneurship and it's not your fault
by the way
your fatal flaw is you haven't been
punched in the [ __ ] mouth yet for
everybody that's sitting we've lived
through the meltdown of the economy in
2008 and 2001 and 1996 and on and on and
on everybody here who's rolling right
now has rolled under ridiculous easy
game ridiculous easiness of global
economy unlimited [ __ ] money in the
system doesn't take a hero to raise
capital and lose money every month and
so the only thing I asked for everybody
who's sitting in your mortal welcome to
sit sit down thank you for everybody who
is standing the one thing I want you to
understand is that truth in the same way
that it's straight worship that people
say Millennials are entitled and are
lazy it's the same that you have to
understand that you have not been
punched in the mouth you have not woken
up in the morning and thirty percent of
the money in the economy has been taken
out and then another week later fifty
percent and all those brand deals
because you got a lot of Instagram
followers go away and so I implore
everybody in this room regardless of
where you are to get real practical the
two businesses I built my dad's liquor
store for him and vaynermedia for me and
my brother I built when I started them
in really tough economies adversity was
my strength it wasn't easy
there was no raising capital I've run
two companies my entire life for all my
garyvee time from the day I left school
at 22 years old to the way I'm standing
right now and those 20 years there has
not been a single day in my life that I
have not operated a business and there's
not been a single time in that entire 20
year period where I didn't make more
money than I lost so I could pay my
bills
it's called practicality it's called
building an actual business and so it's
cool that you have a t-shirt
with a logo on it and you're a lifestyle
fashion brand until the economy crashes
and you have to work at [ __ ] Rogers
[Applause]
now look look don't get it twisted I'm
not on a hike or standing up here saying
I'm successful and you're not yet or
anything cool like that I'm desperate
for you to win and for you to win you
have to have business principles you
have to be able to sustain your business
and you have to understand that when
there's an abundance that is not always
going to be the way it's going to be and
so are you with your profits if you're
crushing it are you putting that back
into your business or saving that or you
buying dumb [ __ ] to look good on
Instagram these are things you have to
think about this is real life and real
life will rear its head very soon sooner
than later I have no idea if I did I
would play the markets that way nobody
really understands when Hauer for what
reason but it's just the way it's always
been and guess what I don't feel
comfortable when the global economy is
getting close to a decade of prosperity
because it usually isn't able to hold on
that long now there's been enormous
amounts of manipulation of government's
supporting it but fundamentals are
fundamentals and so I stand here today
trying to get people into the right
mindset of the yin and yang of what's
happening which is both things are true
a it's unbelievable that things have
been so good for so long and it's a good
time to start strategizing what if what
if I can't raise any money for my
business does my business make money
what if what if the biggest companies in
the world and startups and other
businesses go out of business and they
don't have money to give me what if at
the same token what makes this time
tricky is that the internet is starting
to hit such a scale and such an
opportunity that there is a land grab
and more opportunity than ever for the
individual businesses and anything else
it's incredible to me that you can start
a brand from zero have a smart Instagram
and Facebook strategy sell it on Shopify
plus and Amazon and build a real
business in a year or two that is
remarkable that is incredible and that
is what makes this Bureau special let me
tell you this
and I referenced it earlier my friends
humans will look back at this era they
will look back at this year like you are
living in one of those interesting times
that will be reviewed over and over and
over because you live during the era of
the internet being established a
blockchain being established this is big
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is big [ __ ] sure
this is printing press this is big this
is big big big big big and so now what
you have to do is be on the offense
practically there's people in the
defense
there's people fear mongering technology
right right
watch the subtleties we're [ __ ] on
technology we're blaming Facebook
because we don't like to blame ourselves
right Facebook didn't vote for you
[ __ ]
and so and so and so we live in an
incredible time where the opportunity
for the entrepreneur the educator the
stay-at-home mom
the litigator this is for everybody
my biggest plea here today is for
everybody who is sitting down if you're
47 years old and you think you're
finished you need to rethink everything
I am so frustrated by watching all the
teenagers and 20 year olds take full
advantage of this opportunity because
they don't know any better and for the
40 and 50 and 60 year olds closing their
mind without realizing that they're
gonna live for the next 40 years and
this [ __ ] land grab is for you too
and good news hold [ __ ] you have
experience
forty-two I'm not [ __ ] done not a
baby I just understand how good the
opportunity is and I struggle with my 46
and 59 and 60 70 year old friends who
think because that's how we grew up that
they're getting to the end of the years
without recognizing how much healthier
we are as a race in our 70s 80s and 90s
you compound how fast medicine is
advancing there's a farm I mean if
you're if you're 40 to 60 in this room
your numbers are gonna look like a
hundred 110 I'm like what do people
think is happening here and if you're 63
in this room and you're living another
50 years you're only at half time but
when we grew up
you were towards the end and I am
imploring everybody in this room from
the youngest the [ __ ] in this room to
the oldest the [ __ ] in this room I'm
imploring you I'm imploring you to
understand how incredible this is which
is the following
Ronald [ __ ] Reagan ran the free world
with a computer not as powerful as this
only five minutes ago shit's happening
and you need to take advantage of your
thing and the fact that most of you are
not taking advantage of this opportunity
because of the insecurities that your
[ __ ] up parents or your neighborhood
gave to you breaks my [ __ ] heart and
I am completely obsessed with putting
out content that scale to get people to
understand that not posting on things on
social media because Johnny pants 47
said you're ugly or stupid
watching my 60 year old friends not do
things because they feel weird of the
judgement of their grandkids making fun
of them that they don't understand how
to use snapchat remind your 13 year old
granddaughter that she doesn't know jack
[ __ ] about life
and so I really really need people to
understand what's actually
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
I got you good hustle couple things if
you sit in this room and you have many
business ambitions any business
ambitions any ambitions to raise money
for the disease that took your parents
life if you have any ambitions to raise
money for your school to build a new gym
or any other thing in the world please
understand the following if you do not
understand how to make written words
pictures and videos on Facebook and
Instagram and do not do that multiple
times a day every day you are missing
the [ __ ] boat if you sit in this room
today and do not know how to post
pictures written words and videos and
then how to run ads as little as fifty
dollars up to as much as you can afford
to spend on Facebook and Instagram you
are missing your [ __ ] moment this has
only happened on the Internet
one other chapter at this scale to make
impact this quickly it was called the
Google era Google was grossly
underpriced ads people didn't understand
in 2000 of 2004 but a couple people did
Amazon understood which is why it was
the biggest advertiser on Google during
those years when we have a moment when
there is underpriced attention you have
to go all-in how many people here play
poker
great
[Music]
I I don't because I recognize people
have better math skills than me and I
don't wanna lose my [ __ ] money but I
know enough to know that when you have
the best hand you go all-in Facebook and
Instagram ads right this minute are the
best hand if you are not reinvesting in
your business or your ambitions by
putting ads into Facebook and Instagram
you will regret hearing this for me
today in four years when you look back
and realize it now cost you ten times as
much to get to as many people and it
works half as well because we got too
used to ads on those platforms I don't
care what your opinions are I don't give
a [ __ ] that you ready you've ran on
thousand dollars and it didn't work
it means you didn't know what the [ __ ]
you were doing I don't get any of your
ROI from a basketball other people do I
don't get any ROI out of a piano other
people do the ROI out of Facebook and
Instagram ads is so gross so remarkable
that you have to go home and Google how
do I run Instagram ads enter how do I
get the most effect for Facebook ads for
a real estate agent in the Toronto
region enter you have to figure this out
because it is the best piece of advice
that I can give you on stage and your
romantic point of view that Facebook's
not cool anymore or that you ran it
already or you don't get it or you don't
like the people on their phones anymore
your romantic points of view or your
headline reading points of view is the
vulnerability for your upside you have
to be a practitioner the amount of
people here who have opinions on
influencer marketing on Facebook ads on
snapchat filters opinions on all these
things without ever running a [ __ ] ad
is egregious so the number one thing I
implore everybody here to do is to go
home and become a practitioner at two
things first deploy self-awareness and
figure out how you want to speak to the
world whether as a person or a business
is it written word is it audio or is it
video second understand how to run ads
if you have a
money to run ads on Instagram and
Facebook period end of story I literally
can leave right now and have given you
more value if you actually take it
serious I know for a lot of you have
been following me for a long time you've
heard this before many of times I just
know that none of you have gone all-in
on it enough for the value because even
I'm not going in enough for the value
because the opportunity is so ridiculous
right and so what happens how many
people have been doing their thing and
it's going well for over five years
raise your hand raise them high be proud
awesome you're the ones that I'm most
scared of because you get caught in your
patterns of what was successful for you
this is what always happens right
YouTube works for Salon guy you get
caught you get used to it it feels right
you don't think about it or you get
caught up in headlines you get lazy
you know it's lazy when Instagram
creates stories and you don't think you
need to do snapchat anymore cuz it's the
same you're a [ __ ] idiot you're an
idiot cuz hundreds of 180 million people
a day you snapchat and get more
consumption there and snatch I can make
one change that gets everybody back but
you don't want to put the extra effort
for an extra minute or two to get your
content there it's so fascinating to me
how many people's actions don't match
their ambitions
how many people roll up on me whether
virtually or in real life and tell me
they're gonna buy the rams or the
Raptors or something other than the Jets
cuz we're cool like that and then I go
look at their Twitter handle and they're
watching entire seasons in the [ __ ]
crown on Netflix
our actions are not matching our
ambitions but let me say this and this
is just facts the fact that you're in
this hall this afternoon on this day
means that you see the world in a very
competitive advantage way you understand
that something is happening in a way
that you understand that I'm promising
you 97 98 percent of society doesn't
that is your great strength that you
understand this thing is real this is
real you may not be fully advanced you
may be in the nuances you might not be
grated Instagram but you're good at
YouTube you've got a sense how many
people here have been following me for
longer than 18 months raise your hand
thank you and for 18 months or less
thank you the reason the hands are
fairly even is something changed 15 16
months ago I took the advice that I've
been giving you for the last eight to
ten minutes one of the things that I'm
most proud of is I never talk about [ __ ]
I don't do when I tell you to bleed out
your [ __ ] eyes I plan out of my eyes
when I tell you to spend more money and
time figuring out these platforms I did
it I don't guess you know why I don't
have a lot to say on crypto and Bitcoin
is cuz I'm still tasting you know I
don't have my official vero point of
view it's because I'm tasting I don't
like to talk about [ __ ] until I know
what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
the last ten minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
ten minutes of trying to get you there
and like pushing forcefully it's because
that's what happened to me 15 months ago
even for all my winning and I was
followed by a lot of people and a lot of
people knew who I was I wasn't all the
way in right I was busy with Manor I was
doing other things but Boehner got big
enough and my financial situation got
big enough but that I was able to take
it from just me making my content to
three and a half years later being 17
people and a complete media team that
helps me put out the obnoxious amount of
content I did a lot of people have a lot
more money than me they're more than
welcome to hire people and go all in on
this they choose to take those dollars
and buy things that were invested or do
whatever they want as they should I just
want everybody to understand one thing
attention is the asset before you tell
me what you want to accomplish or what
you want the customer to do whatever the
customer is get a vote sign up for your
platform you know whatever you want them
to do you need their attention attention
in our society lives here and more
importantly it's underpriced right now
in the ad products and the opportunity
for the youngsters in this room it feels
normal so you can't realize how good it
is for the people that are older they've
seen this show before television
commercials in the 70s Google ads in the
mid-2000s email marketing in 94 95 it
just sometimes they don't understand the
pattern recognition I'm sitting here
today telling you one simple thing if
you are not communicating to the world
on these platforms you're invisible fix
it thank you
you guys you know have a lot of time so
we're gonna move quickly if you do have
questions there are mics on this side
and that side get lined up you know I
think this is a good time for a quick
but cozy fireside chat what do you guys
think yeah okay so get your questions
ready I can't emphasize enough the pace
is gonna have to move quickly
oh and look at that ha ha ha
thank you well so guys a couple quick
rules about the Q&A Stewart a couple
quick ground rules we don't have a lot
of time so please no pitching if you're
going up to pitch a business an idea of
whatever please do not do it keep in
mind that there are a lot of people here
we want to deliver value please Nick
let's go yeah there we go
and no selfies guys so so Gary
[Applause]
[Applause]
Thanks
that person okay there's
somebody is checking the insurance
policy as we speak let's do this okay
Gary so uh as we got some people want up
there I got a couple things to kick it
off here so after ten plus years
preaching social social media marketing
what are people still getting wrong
in your opinion I think how early it is
I just think it's early like I don't
know what else to say Facebook is
trading at $8 CPMs on average it should
be 50 based on the attention Instagram
stories of trading at five four three
grossly underpriced it's just early like
the land grab is real and so I just
think people are still debating while
it's actually happening so you know at
vaynermedia do you see a disconnect
between what clients think they want
versus what they actually need of course
there's not a single client at
vaynermedia that does what I think they
should you know that's not which is okay
listen it's their money I'm in client
services I want to give them the right
strategies but they measure things that
I don't believe in like reporting and
rewards and internal modeling mixes that
favor television big companies are in
trouble right now in the world because
they're wrong
the wrong like they think you watch
commercials
so you you have a great speech there
about you know the value of Facebook Ads
Instagram ads you know I think there's a
lot of people especially in the audience
that you know may not have the
investment or are prepared to kind of
take that leap onto the paid side and
are still looking for their angle on
kind of the organic and I think there's
a lot of people that are hung up on the
old golden that yeah there's the golden
days of Facebook organic reach and
people got used to but it was [ __ ]
free yeah you know like it was free why
are you mad that the reaches down it's
free your email reaches down to my email
open rates in 1998 were in 1997 were
seventy eighty ninety percent it's all
cops and robbers cat-and-mouse like the
only reason Facebook's doing that is if
you guys all saw ads all day you believe
they're protecting their product
meanwhile in parallel the ads are
grossly underpriced but you've made an
emotional decision that you like the
better when it was free and you value
that versus understanding that if you
spent a dollar you can make ten they're
just not smart do you think there is
anywhere right now where content
creators can gain an edge prior to
making that leap to paid like for
example when you I don't understand why
that matters like the pain is
underpriced now it matters if you have
no money so if you have no money go to
Craigslist go to the free section right
pick up people's free [ __ ] flip it on
Facebook marketplace make yourself 500
dollars by sweating a little bit and
then run at nice guys okay let's take
some questions why they're not guys I
used to own the word wine for five cents
a click under on Google I owned it it
was five cents a click it's not five
cents a click anymore you know why it's
not 2001 anymore and you guys know what
the [ __ ] Google is like it's under
priced ads right now take advantage of
it because they won't be I don't know
what else to tell you
do you have a favorite placement right
now you mean in terms of like you know
you can advertise on Instagram stories
you can do right side column newsfeed do
you have a favorite is just speaking
it's just feed cuz that's where people
see stuff more importantly I want to
make sure you also understand the
difference between brand and sales a lot
of you are struggling because you just
want to sell and all you're doing is
throwing the right hook and maybe
somebody doesn't want your piece of [ __ ]
$400 ebook okay let's get a question
from this side of the room here good
afternoon I'm Holly and I'm one of these
old women in the room okay over 50
respect you look great thank you
throw it out good for you
and what would be the biggest piece of
advice about where you making cuz I've
been here I've done it help to that lot
successfully they're doing well good on
to the 3rd yep okay okay well what are
you trying to accomplish reinvent when
you say we embed yourself try to get
street cred and notoriety and like yeah
I've always played the field of personal
finance I say the considered one of
Canada's leading personal finance
writers so here's what I would say and
this you know I went through this when I
kind of transitioned from wine to like
more business content I didn't think a
lot about establishing myself I thought
a lot about doing investing in Facebook
and Twitter and Tumblr early on building
vaynermedia from 0 to 200 million that
was my reinvent it don't worry about
what the [ __ ] they think go and execute
a successful launch and then you will be
that it's the same thing with names do
you know many people here [ __ ] spend
weeks coming up with their company name
like - years I pick a month yeah that's
a dumb [ __ ] move here's why
name's army you think me look ten
[ __ ] Hortons is a great name names
are made Google's not a great name
snapchats not a great name these are
just they become great names because of
the actions not because the name Gary
[ __ ] V with two silent knees are you
[ __ ] ready so make it the execution
don't worry about establishing yourself
the results always [ __ ] speak let's
take one from this side of the room yeah
hey Gary how you doing my name is
Sheldon Bruce from two line music Hut
and I've been following you about the
past year Thank You Shelly you
definitely changed my life that's last
week I got my first three thousand
dollar check because of you
thank you alright what I wanted actually
is what is your take on hustle versus
investor I believe in both I don't think
they're conflicting right I think hustle
is investing when you don't have money
like you have money or your time
like you know and so like I think that
both are essential
I love investing financially I love
investing in people I love investing in
my audience which is why I put out my
content for free right
I think investing is just smart it feels
good and more importantly shall I
started this talk with it which is
unless like look I leave a lot of
economics on the table every year now if
I die tomorrow from a business
standpoint I left something on the table
but for the most part if I don't it will
pay its dividends over the course of a
50-year career I shall be you and every
single person here has never met anybody
who's been successful without them
working hard and hustling you may know
somebody who has a lot of money right
that they were given that money but
nobody here has achieved without a lot
of hard work hard work is a prerequisite
like yes
the smarter and you work the bigger the
upside talent matters but to me Hustle
is ox
because it's the number one piece of
advice I can give to every single person
here and it doesn't matter how good
smart or clever or what they see is it
is a variable of success so I'm a big
believer both those thank you thank you
sir good way thank you my podcast all
right a hundred percent done I'll do it
thank you this is crazy my birthday
right now thank you I don't know 23
exactly on Thursday thanks us on thank
you to all the agenda Jen solos out here
too for kind of Nick Gabriela but I'm
just I just wanted to ask you a quick
question I so I just partnered up with
my buddy we're doing a hockey apparel
company called just ish and hockey were
based out of Buffalo New York okay my
question to you is so we're big on or
big on for online shopping right now of
course my question for you is how can we
increase our conversion rates well have
better product okay I mean that's you
know a lot of people don't think about
that right because they only think about
you know conversion rate has a lot to do
with what's happening once they're there
right right so either your landing page
your UI your UX the copy the images are
not grabbing people right the other way
you can do it is by building brand right
so there's sales and brand but these get
into the like finite details I would
screen eyes very heavily the shopping
cart experience where the drop-off is
this is all math you know like where
where the buttons are have the baby
tested the color of the ad to carpet and
a lot of technical stuff and then comma
are you building brand because people
convert better when they trust will feel
emotion so if they've heard of you on
Instagram or on a podcast or things of
that nature they'll feel more confident
once they get to that moment of truth so
it's about black and white technical
nuances of a website you know mobile
optimization things of that nature
and number two really are you
establishing a brand that becomes
trusted or loved Gary how do you
balance between the you know not getting
too stuck in them my new details of the
green or red button like where's the
balance between the data and then
playing off the emotion for rule I don't
get stuff because if you become too mad
doubt you become commoditized there's a
lot of people here and a great at math
they believe only in analytics and quant
and it gets them to a certain place cuz
it's an absolute strength but it's also
the same reason they tap out cuz the
math always plays out if math was the
variable the game would be over by now
the art matters so incredible and so for
me I intuitively understand the art
quite well and I surround myself with
the biggest [ __ ] nerds I can find on
the map those are two variables you have
hey just one more question go fast can I
give you my business card sure you wanna
loosen up I won't look at it that way
what's that I will definitely throw your
business card at the airport okay that's
fine but you can tweet me and be like
I'm the 23 year old birthday boy who's
got the website and that gives you a 13%
chance I'll look at
okay guys that's all we have time for
today you guys are are you guys rushing
because of my heart out because I'll
sneak in two more okay you guys want to
do do more let's go okay right side
thanks for the ticket you're welcome
I came from London thank you you may
remember last year someone offered you
to do a backflip for an internship and
what a backflip for an internship
yes said no yes and I'm gonna be the
first to ask this question in this form
and I'm also the first to get a Gary
Busey crushing it in London so my
question is I'll pay you $15 an hour
that's the same amount that you paying
into them that's right and I'll intern
for you but two years ago you said I can
be an intern and you said yes for this
year I reversed I reversed and said I'll
pay you to do so let's break this down
three years ago I said yes who can be an
intern but we didn't make it happen
you said you know Anakin did that's the
most important part so Val and where are
you in London yeah okay so we have to
fix that so email me at Gary of
vaynermedia yeah forward the original
email yep
right and I'll make that happen and you
can keep your 15 bucks I made a
documentary called Gary do Gary the
building the honey Empire and the
premiere is on the 8th of March in
vaynermedia London yes would you be
interested in a 10-minute Q&A session
down there whilst you're there
first up time to debate how hard I
should sue your [ __ ] face send me the
details about
okay one more question guys this is the
last question I'll be really quick here
yeah I heard you're a big fan of altoon
now - AL - my favorite all-time your cat
would you accept this small gift for
being here today from me you have some
sort of Altoona thing maybe you better
answer yes yes yes come on up all right
next one go faster yeah hey brother you
sneaked a couple of good there's one
hole hardly thank you and probably like
99.9% of the people here you've done so
much fun me but for everybody in this
room and because of you is why I'm here
man 9 half years ago I discovered you we
don't vote we go back and it's because
of you I'm almost at 500,000 subscribers
on YouTube it's because of you is why in
crushing it thanks to you and just thank
you thank you bro
two quick things I'm gonna let you ask
well you can do it two minutes please
I'll be one minute awesome
okay real quick for all of you and
Sheldon so long dude guys I'm just the
see it's cuz of you I'm [ __ ] pounding
people 24/7 365 have hundreds of
millions of people at this point consume
the content and 99.9% of them aren't
doing dick about it it's cuz of you and
you Sheldon that you're actually making
it happen
I'm just the [ __ ] kernel
the architecture taking this question my
name is Aaron Spivak I got a quick
question for you you're actually the
reason I dropped out of school four
years ago it's your parents here they
weren't happy at the time but they're
pretty happy now so it's all [ __ ]
figure anyways last four years my
brothers and I we built the franchise
now seven locations actually in the city
we sell cold fresh juices but what's
been happening is I've been spending my
time on nights on some other things okay
and I want to know how you feel about
diversifying streams of income for me I
mean other people are like you should be
putting 110% into that one thing which I
am but I mean I think that your
entrepreneurial and your curious and
even if what you're doing at night
completely fails you needed to scratch
that [ __ ] and it's a hundred percent
ROI positive is growing crazy right now
go figure
there's only so many hours in the day I
mean I can sleep for every night but at
some point listen I think it comes down
to are you willing to [ __ ] your brothers
[Applause]
[Music]